[Music]
in the late 30s and early 40s there was
no bigger musical act than Glenn Miller
and his orchestra the big band leader
wrote in performed dozens of top ten
hits and sold millions of records but in
the midst of World War two Miller gave
up his lucrative career and enlisted in
the military where he led the u.s. army
air force band various high-grade
orchestras throughout the United States
[Music]
it was in his service to his country
that Miller lost his life anxious to
bring his band to troops on the European
front Miller took off from England on
December 15 1944 bound for Paris his
plane disappeared over the English
Channel major Glenn Miller director of
the US Air Force Band is missing on a
flight from England to Paris it was
announced today and the fate of Glenn
Miller's lost flight has been a mystery
ever since but there could soon be an
answer the only way to change mysteries
history is to come up with solid
documentation Ric Gillespie from the
international group for historic
aircraft recovery or tiger says an
English fisherman has provided the most
solid lead in decades on where to find
the wreckage of Miller's plane in 1987
trawling in the English Channel he
pulled up an airplane wreck that he
later realized looked like the kind of
airplane that Glenn Miller disappeared
in he called the Coast Guard described
it they said well if it's a world war
two airplane it might be a war grave you
know I just get rid of it the fisherman
made a note of where he dropped the
wreckage but it wasn't until years later
when he saw a picture of what Miller's
Norseman aircraft looked like that he
realized what he might have discovered
Gillespie who has extensively researched
Amelia Earhart's disappearance says if
the wreckage can be found tracing it
back to Miller
should be an easy
asked since it was the only aircraft
with its body and engine type to go
missing during the war you find the
steel tube fuselage you find the engine
you found the Miller airplane possibly
putting an end to one of America's
greatest unsolved mysteries these things
always start with a story and this is
classic yes a fisherman's story you know
the one that got away yeah who's
remaining anonymous right now
Gillespie's group still isn't decided if
there's enough information for them to
do a full hope you find it all right